[Music]
the effect of all the sexual harassment
scandals has had a long-lasting effect
here in Hollywood as we prepare for the
Golden Globes several stars are expected
to wear black as a show of solidarity
yeah it's gonna be quite the statement
and a lot that a lot of the men are
joining into to show their support and
this morning curly still talk to the
host of the globe Seth Meyers about how
this serious issue will impact the show
we're just having a constant discussion
about it understanding that the things
we're talking about aren't always funny
so it'll be a balance and trying to get
the tone right you know what also trying
to remember that
even though it was a really difficult
year people did great work who should be
most worried during your monologue I
will say that the people that should be
most worried won't be here for the
reasons we alluded to earlier three
today Seth helped unroll the red carpet
and put the moet on ice but come Sunday
expect a more somber celebration last
night in New York City nominees Saoirse
Ronan and Timothy shalt amazed that they
will join the many men and women
attendees for participating in Sunday's
red-carpet blackout I think it'll just
send a really sort of strong message
it's an honor to be a part of this new
wave and new generation of show business
that's way more conscientious about
these things
the movement was orchestrated by the
tides up coalition it consists of 300
powerful women in Hollywood including
Meryl Streep Eva Longoria Emma Stone
Jessica Chastain and Reese Witherspoon I
tanja nominee Allison Janney who will
also wear black on Sunday told ET how
instrumental Reese wasn't getting the
word out Reese has a lot of friends and
her friends told their print you know
it's just sort of the you know network
of women who found out and there's a
little bit of a misconception that it's
a silent protest but obviously it is not
because the actresses want people ask
them why they're wearing black so they
can speak out from a voice